[Music]
you're Irish right
[Laughter]
well I'm German Irish okay so your face
isn't lying to me yeah Oh what you think
Jeremy's don't look you know with
remember Boris Becker dominating
Wimbledon the first positive thing that
happened to German people because a
Hitler right hey ruined it for like 40
years so happy you're saying that a nice
German tennis player brought back some
glory to German stomping yeah it's just
like I remember when the German kid used
to visit in the when they did the
exchange program yes and they would come
to our high school and that's all we
would say well you a Nazi I'm wait yeah
yeah yeah we were kids we didn't know
any better I get Kroners at this show
man
it really just burst it was this thing's
about relationships
hey everybody who knows me that's how
you start the block everybody who knows
me knows I have a great sense of humor I
love all kinds of that you do the build
up of how awesome the open-minded a
person you are
however we actually we talked about
Nazis on the pilot which we actually
have a do you mind if we show a clip
this is from the private Airways she
already cueing it up no don't show it
all the clips were supposed to be
cleared by me and my people well they
show there's an eyelash I can't get rid
of the dimpling I want to learn how to
speak German just because I want to know
what he's saying in those speeches oh my
gosh it looks like he's saying what he
wants to do like you know kill everybody
like there's no way he's saying that
he's got to be saying something out
about a package it and then I'd be
talking about their awesome cars yeah
and their beer who's got to be talking
trash
you know guess a lot of hear me out
showing off the pasty guns in this deal
pgz women love them are you
[Music]